makeshift flash suits Kryptonian
callbacks and Bruce Wayne still getting
nuts he has a breakdown of some of the
teasers and the Easter eggs that may
have flashed by you in the latest Flash
trailer
the trailer's opening moments take
viewers back to Wayne Manor but it looks
quite different from the building
depicted in Tim Burton's Batman movies
while the mano's exterior is slightly
obscured by Mist this one seems to be
much grander than the one we've seen
before why could this be well Burton's
first movie use the iconic nebworth
house to film The exteriors of Wayne
Manor hence the flash seems have
followed suits as filming took place
there in 2021 of course it's been over
three decades since the release of
Burton's Batman so it's quite possible
that the building has had some work done
between then and 2021 in Universe Bruce
Wayne could have done the same in 1989's
Batman Wayne Manor is mainly shown when
the guests enter the car park at a wider
rate of fancy Vehicles The Flash meme
while sees Bruce and Barry walked down a
long footpath toward the front doors
it's entirely possible that we're seeing
a side of the building that simply
hasn't been shown until now hopefully
the trailer for The Flash reminds us of
Batman's parents are dead just in case
you didn't know however this flick
features two older and wiser iterations
of Bruce Wayne both whom have had
decades to process their grief these
brutal life experiences make Batman the
perfect father figures for Barry Allen
Another Hero who understands a grief of
losing his parents in their scenes with
the flash the Dark Knights reveal that
painters inform their entire beings
Michael Keaton's Batman tells flash her
pain
made me who I am Ben Affleck's version
meanwhile informs Alan he scores real
guess who we are it's not all doom and
gloom though as bat flick also
encourages a young hero to not let that
pain Define him the trailer suggests
that Batman will have Mentor roles in
the Flash and who knows maybe other
iterations of The Dark Knight will turn
up to share their own words of wisdom
The Flash Stars no one but two Barry
Allen's to make the experience easier to
digest both flashes of visually distinct
costumes in the latest trailer flash
number one is sporting a Comics Acura
red and gold super onesie with lightning
bolt embellishments and Flash number two
is sporting it's something else what is
that exactly homemade body armor it's
weirdly clunky for a Speedster now this
new costume is barely on screen for more
than a second and is never seen up close
so it's hard to say for sure but it sure
looks like flash number two is strapped
inside of a repurposed Batman costume
look at it again you'll notice a red
coloring appears to be a slap Dash paint
job with streaks of black peeking
through and that lightning bolt Insignia
is definitely painted over a different
logo but the Clincher here is a
hilariously thick cowl a staple feature
of Michael Keaton's original Batman
design it looks like the second Barry
borrowed Batman's suit and spruced it up
at the nearest Michaels which is
actually pretty on brand for the Flash
more The Flash will indulcerly have its
fair share of surprises DC dropped a few
cryptic teasers in the latest trailer
one interesting moment shows a
mysterious figure standing behind the
child at Suds Kryptonian terraforming
device begins its destruction the
blinking new music character comes on
screen just as we see Barry running into
the city so those not paying close
attention may assume it's him standing
behind the kid but it's not or is it the
mystery character looks like they threw
together their outfit at the last second
sporting what appears to be random
pieces of orange black and white armor
unlike the rest of the characters and
the shots the character isn't running
away from the destruction so it
definitely gives off the vibe that
there's some sort of hero the most
realistic candidate would be the other
Barry who features throughout the
trailer this scene might simply take
place before he gets his final outfit
however flash points the comic on which
the Flash's base features countless DC
characters so technically this could be
anyone it's certainly no innocent
bystander that's the Joker once asked
those toys of course one of the toys
that the cape's Crusader has at his
disposal in that movie is his jet
fighter actually named the Batwing this
highly stylized aircraft has placed
front and center in this new trailer for
The Flash which is not a huge surprise
since van managed just a rich guy
without any real superpowers he needs
some way to get around indeed the
Batwing looks to be an integral part of
the flash you may remember the vehicle
from a number of Batman movies but
perhaps its most iconic screen moments
sees Batman scoop up the Joker's
poisonous parade balloons during the
climax of Burton and Keaton's 1989
Batman movie of course the Joker isn't
the biggest fan and he quickly brings
down the batwing with a comically
oversized handgun whether or not the
Batwing featured in The Flash is that
version or a new one it's nice to see
that Keaton's Batman still has his wings
those who have read DC Comics Flashpoint
will be all too familiar with what's to
come in The Flash and it certainly looks
like audiences will see Barry Allen and
Bruce Wayne's Infamous lightning
experiment on the big screen in
Flashpoint Barry wakes up in an
alternate reality where his mother never
died and he never became the flash he
soon realizes that this new world is
much worse than the one he left behind
so he contacts Thomas Wayne this reality
is Batman to help him get his powers
back the two attempt to recreate the
lightning strike that gave Barry his
super speed but the first attempt fails
leaving Barry covered in horrible burns
the trailer for The Flash offers fans
quick glimpses of a similar experiment
that's one point we see one hand
touching another twitching smoking hand
later we get another glimpse of Barry
strapped into a chair as blue Lightning
Sparks all around him the flash isn't a
direct adaptation of Flashpoint but it
seems safe to save fans will see Barry
fighting to get his powers back
this new trailer offers plenty of
footage featuring both the original
Barry Allen and the alternate timeline
Barry but it's conspicuously missing a
few important aspects of the Flash's
story traditionally Barry tends to lose
the parents or parents to a villainous
Speedster usually reverse flash so what
does this trailer tell us about the
movie's potential secret antagonist well
this Flash trailer shows the alternate
timeline Barry far angrier than we've
seen him before it's very possible then
that he could end up adults with our
Barry since the footage we've seen so
far only features two speedsters and
since it's pretty unlikely that the
central character will break bad it's
possible that the other version of Barry
will indeed grow disillusioned with the
main flash or perhaps become corrupted
by the speed force turning Barry Allen
into His Own Worst Enemy would certainly
be a novel approach to the flashes
speeds to heavy Rogues gallery and
making this particular version of
reverse flash responsible for the death
of Barry's parents might just be one of
the biggest blows any superhero has ever
faced is The Flash willing to go there
or are there other as yet unseen forces
at Play
drawing the trailer Kara's or Rao gives
Barry Allen a pop quiz on Kryptonian
symbols you know what the symbol stands
for
means hope right it's a brief scene but
this acts as a huge callback to Man of
Steel during that movie Superman
explains the same thing about the
s-shaped shield on his uniform it's not
an s
on my world it means hope with the
weight of saving the world resting on
her shoulders it looks like Cara will
literally carry her family's mantle on
her chest she will now be the symbol of
hope her cousin once was and since Clark
definitely wasn't the type to give up on
the good in the world it's likely that
this philosophy will be carried through
with Kara
fans of DC Comics Flashpoint event know
that an array of heroes and villains
appear in the universe altering story
arc Superman Aquaman Wonder Woman and
Cyborg all play pivotal roles in the
story so the flash could be hiding any
number of cameos while it's clear that
Supergirl is taking Superman's place in
the movie could the Man of Steel himself
somehow make an appearance at one point
the trailer for The Flash shows
Supergirl flying through the clouds
carrying a shirtless man we never see
the face of the mystery character but
could it possibly be a dead or weakened
color in the flashpoint Comics flash
Cyborg and Batman rescue a frail
Superman who has been a prisoner since
his arrival on Earth could The Flash
Loosely adapt this for Supergirl finding
her cousin in a death-like state forcing
her to fly him up towards the sun on the
other hand it could just be Barry who
needs to be closer to the storm to get
struck by lightning while it seems
highly unlikely that Henry Cavill
secretly returned for yet another DC
Cameo The Flash is definitely keeping
some of things hidden for its theatrical
release so anything could be possible
as you can probably tell this new
trailer for The Flash is absolutely
filled to the rim with callbacks and
references to previous films within the
DC Multiverse Michael Keaton's Batman
steals are show naturally and audiences
are treated to costumes vehicles and
even famous lines from other movies take
this for example you want to get nuts
let's get nuts this is actually a
reference to a famous line from 1989's
Batman film at one point in the movie
Keaton's Bruce Wayne is at Vicky vale's
apartment and the Joker bursts in with
his gang in tow when the Joker attempts
to intimidate Bruce Bruce for taught by
flashing a hint of his own rage and
aggressive posture
come on let's get nuts hopefully it
works out better for Bruce this time
around
[Music]